the following conversation is with ryan
selkis ryan is the founder of masari in
this conversation we talk about gbtc's
attempt to convert to an etf we talk
crypto regulation the contagion in the
market and many more other topics i
really enjoyed this conversation with
ryan and i hope that you guys enjoy it
as well don't forget that these episodes
are brought to you by ftx us they've got
cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
cheaper than their competitors you can
click on the link in the description to
go learn more about ftx let's get in
this episode with ryan i hope you guys
enjoy it i'm very excited to talk to
ryan ryan what's going on man
good to see you man i feel uh
underdressed
it's the first time i've ever seen a
suit and tie all the time
it's totally a new podcast well listen
this is uh my bear market costume i wore
this during the 2008 2019 bear market
defeated that bad boy and so i figured
we could use some help and i'm going to
wear this uh whether i want to or not i
promise everyone i would wear it until
the bear market's over so we need to
turn this bad boy around
so i can stop wearing it let's do it
all right uh there's a ton of stuff for
us to talk about maybe we can start with
uh gbtc
and their uh hope to be converted to a
etf
uh they were denied in their most recent
etf application by the sec and within
hours turned around and sued the sec
what is your general read on the
situation and what do you think their
prospects are uh going to court uh in
terms of actually being successful with
this lawsuit
i should think that their prospects are
pretty good but you know before we get
into all that i think we have to talk
about gbtc what it is how it works um
the
the havoc that is created in the market
and um the scc's really
uh indefensible position around its
potential conversion to an etf so
basically grayscale is the largest asset
manager on crypto they have a set of
passive funds that track bitcoin ether
or some of the other top assets and then
they have a couple that are baskets of
assets you know kind of like a top 10
crypto acid index but the big one is
gbtc and then to a slightly you know
lesser extent they're ethy products and
these products have come to market
and basically started trading otc not
actual etfs but otc through this
loophole in securities law that
essentially allows them to raise money
from private investors and then after a
six-month holding period those investors
can sell the shares
that represent the assets in the
underlying trust
on the open market and the way that an
etf works is you can continuously create
and redeem
baskets of shares that represent the
interest and the underlying trust so
if for whatever reason the share price
deviates from
the underlying spot price of the
commodity that's held in the trust
you have brokers that are incentivized
to make the market and basically
arbitrage away those differences so if
the spot price is
is higher than the price per share
you're going to redeem shares and just
convert to the underlying asset and vice
versa right if the share price is higher
you're going to want to sell those
shares
and then use that to create you know
more more assets in the trust and so you
have this continuous feedback loop that
keeps the spot price the underlying etf
um relatively close and and in line with
uh what the price of the underlying
commodity is that's how traditional ets
work now grayscale's products don't do
that because this weird loophole so what
does that mean well it's created this
dynamic where historically for a long
time
the shares that traded on the otc
markets were at a premium to the
underlying spot price and the reason was
it was a lot more demand for shares from
different vehicles either retail
investors that wanted in their 401k or
institutional investors didn't really
have any other access
and um up until early last year those
shares traded at a premium
february last year the trade reversed it
trades at a discount now and now the
discounts actually close to 30 percent
but again because this is not an etf
that's a one-way ticket and the
investors that hold the shares cannot
redeem these shares
they can only get liquidity through the
occ market so you don't really have a
path to closing this gap and what this
has done is it's basically created six
billion dollars worth of capital
impairment for the investors in the
trust and these publicly traded shares
with no path to actually recouping the
assets that are in the trust as you
would with an etf
and
this collateral this trade was what
three arrows capital block phi a number
of other
big counterparties ultimately got caught
in
and created a bunch of the losses and
some of this cascading effect that we've
seen in the crypto markets with some of
the uh illiquidity and insolvency issues
at some of the big investors it was a
synthetic trade that went sour and now
everybody's trying to unwind these
positions so
the issue with the grayscale
etf conversion and the fact that it was
rejected again by the sec is the sec is
basically saying
well you know the bitcoin markets aren't
fully surveillable and there's no kind
of shared surveillance agreements
between international exchanges so we
can't guarantee that the market's not
manipulated so we're not going to apply
uh we're not going to approve this etf
conversion the problem is investors
already have access to this thing
and they're hurting to the tune of 6
billion
so i think if you look at that fact
alone plus the fact that the sec
approved futures uh based etfs six
months ago
you have a dynamic where
um the sec doesn't really have a good
leg to stand on because futures are a
derivative of the spot market and those
are inferior products that were approved
late last year and then you've also got
this consumer protection issue so
short of an etf conversion it does look
like the sec is basically engaged in
hostage taking and is waiting until they
have full oversight and surveillance
rights of the underlying crypto markets
in the u.s before they act um now that's
kind of between the lines but i think
that's you know hopefully a good
uh two minute or three minute synopsis
of what's otherwise a really complicated
product for those people to wrap their
heads around
if gbtc
was being managed by a wall street bank
do you think that it would already have
been converted like is this a crypto
company
specific issue
and it's less about the product or is it
about the product and not so much the
company behind it
i think it's a little bit of both to be
honest i mean it's it's tough to prove
uh that
this is you know the reason that uh this
product you know has not been approved i
think it's uh really much more
the case that the sec doesn't want to
reward cleverness and uh and and you
know a product that basically try to
route around them by taking advantage of
this loophole to get to the public
markets even though it's not an etf um
and and even more importantly i think
it's about jurisdiction and it's about
the sec expanding its overreach to
include the likes of coinbase kraken
gemini the other us-based exchanges and
until they get that regulatory authority
what they're going to say is how can we
approve this in good conscience when we
can't actually
guarantee to investors that we have a
good handle on the integrity of the
underlying markets
whose prices we rely on for this product
um and until yeah there's some oversight
of the exchanges themselves that provide
the reference rates that feed these
products and and the underlying share
price um we're just not going to do it
right so it's very black and white um i
think based on a technicality um and and
based on the fact that they're basically
waiting to uh expand their authority and
get you know additional powers from
congress
you've been around for quite a while uh
you've told me the story previously uh
of you tweeting out um and kind of
sharing the information about mount gox
when that failed uh there's been a
number of companies uh some more painful
than others uh who are going through
similar types of situations whether you
know it's just uh hey they're having
stress induced by some of the gbtc and
3ac stuff
some of them are actually shutting down
withdrawals some of them look to have
been engaged in
quite nefarious or bad acting uh you
know kind of situations
how bad is the current crop of this kind
of chaos compared to mount gox when uh
when you first came across it
i think it's arguably worse you know
mount cox most people in the industry at
the time knew it was a shitty exchange
right uh and and it had already had a
number of security issues it was just
the largest
by virtue of being the first right and
that creates a lot of stickiness because
that's where the the majority of the
liquidity was um but you already had
started to see some investors move away
from malcox and do exchanges like
bitstamp and there was a couple of
others at the time
um the
yeah the
the mount gox issue was one of technical
incompetence and um
and theft right um because they had poor
you know kind of risk control security
controls in terms of how they custodied
assets
the reason i say that this is arguably
worse is because of the contagion that
has been created by fraud and poor risk
controls
um
and and by lending in particular right
so you know with mount cox it was that
the funds were stolen with uh all of the
cascading failures that we've seen uh
more recently
it was due to leverage and margin calls
and a bunch of centralized
counterparties that were um
you know i don't want to say gambling i
think gambling's a strong word in some
of these cases but they were they were
essentially speculating um with uh with
customer reserves and making
uh high interest rate markets um but not
really having a good handle on the true
risks at their counter parties so um you
created a series of insolvencies and i
think that there's a big difference
between
um
what you know first of all time right
nine years ago or eight years ago when
when mount cox went under at the the
industry was just significantly smaller
and under the radar from a regulatory
standpoint um and you know you kind of
fast forward to today this is not
something that was you know contained to
just a few bucket shops or you know kind
of poorly managed operations it really
has hit
a lot of the blue chip names
in the industry um and uh and a lot of
multi-billion dollar
companies or investors have have been
impacted uh pretty significantly so
um i think you know mount cox it was
kind of like an isolated incident um it
was terrible right it was it was a huge
chunk of the outstanding supply and it
hurt a lot of investors it took a long
long time
for that to make its way through the
courts but um it was a single entity uh
versus this you know kind of ripple
effect that we've seen
uh with three arrows capital and and and
you know some of that the result of the
bad collateral that three arrows was
subject to with with uh gbtc the other
the other issue is this is
impacting a lot of western players
you know mount gox was uh you know for
uh no matter how you slice it i mean out
of sight out of mind kind of thing it
was you know uh it was the big japanese
exchange of the western you know kind of
leaders thought oh well bitstamps based
in europe and we've got coinbase and
kraken in the u.s so there was western
alternatives um and from
i think just a top of mind standpoint
most of the regulators in the west just
kind of looked at this and said okay you
know we have to have guard rails for
the um the american and kind of
european-led businesses to make sure
that stuff like this can't happen and
all those entities are in fact regulated
but you know it wasn't as catastrophic
as maybe you know it was in japan even
though many u.s customers were um were
exposed what is your expectation for
changes in regulation or disclosures
coming out of kind of all of the last
couple of weeks and the chaos in the
crypto market
i i think that the centralized players
are under-regulated now the the the
issue here is we need to be very careful
about what works and what doesn't and
kind of where the dividing line should
be
because when it comes to the
decentralized lending protocols
you can watch some of these liquidations
happen on chain in real time as they
were happening uh during the liquidity
crisis a couple of weeks ago as the
prices were you know getting uh getting
drawn down and um and that's painful for
whoever's taking out a margin position
on chain but the protocols worked
right and i think some of that is kind
of missing here the real issues were in
the centralized
uh black boxes
that's not on top of this and we're
basically you know holding themselves
out to be
these uh these really robust uh banks
with good risk controls and and and you
know really strong products that were
run by professional teams when in
reality you know they're basically you
know under reserved banks with poor risk
controls
even if they were defrauded you know
some of these companies to have 50
percent of your outstanding loan book be
with one counterparty i mean that's just
piss poor risk management right there's
there's no other way to
to slice it no matter how big three
euros was uh in in terms of you know
it's it's important as an industry
player so i think that's um
that's one of the things that's going to
be hard that's going to be a bill that
can't get on wrong right and and i i
think that um regulating centralized
entities
um
is important and in fact most people
that are serious in the industry talk
about the need to regulate the
centralized entities here that are
handling customer funds that are making
markets and that are facilitating
lending or exchange right i don't know
anyone serious that's arguing against
that what the issue is going to be is
where do we draw the line and can we
ensure that some of the open protocols
and peer-to-peer
financial activity you know like
on-chain lending or like decentralized
exchange is is not touched and it's it's
you know fought for and vigorously
defended so it's not thrown out with the
bath water um when we when we start to
see some more regulations on the
centralized entities um and if we do our
jobs right you know kind of collectively
as an industry i think that's where
we'll end up where the peer-to-peer will
um
will be protected uh and the centralized
entities that look like banks are
regulated like banks centralized
exchanges that operate like new york
stock exchange and and you know nasdaq
they're regulated as such um and you
know that'll ultimately usher in the the
next wave of growth and institutional
adoption so i think everybody wins if we
can get that balance right
talk about the difference between the
centralized platforms and the
decentralized
protocols or platforms and kind of how
their performance has differed
throughout all of this
well it's pretty simple the
decentralized platforms worked and and
you didn't have the ability to shut down
user withdrawals right uh you know some
of these um collateralized vaults if
they were at risk or or you know they
were not um topped up with additional
collateral they did you know get
liquidated but they were liquidated
programmatically according to the rules
of the smart contracts as they were
written
um you contrast that with the
centralized
uh lenders and they just straight up
clause withdrawals because they were
insolvent or close to insolvent and they
had to
basically pause operations this happened
with celsius this happened with voyager
um
and i'd imagine we're not totally out of
the woods just yet there's probably some
other companies that are on the brink
right now in terms of uh insolvency or
trying to limit withdrawals and make
sure that this doesn't cascade further
but um
hopefully the worst very worse is over i
wouldn't i wouldn't be surprised to see
you know another couple of
uh kind of final dying breaths of this
particular liquidity crisis
you given your kind of long uh history
in the bitcoin and crypto industry uh
have seen all forms of bitcoin
maximalism and there appears to be a
great debate uh is bitcoin maximalism
good is it bad is it the same it used to
be what's your take on uh bitcoin
maximalism and many of the people who
kind of are carrying that torch forward
today
um the majority of my investment
portfolio
uh i'd say is bitcoin and then my own
company right so you know when i when i
say what i say next you know i i hope
that people keep this in mind
but um i think bitcoin maximalism is
about as close to brain cancer
um as we have uh short of actual brain
cancer and i think maximalism of all
types
is um is pretty dangerous uh just
in terms of like what you're willing to
fall for and
and and how closed off to opportunities
you could be i don't think bitcoin
maximalism is any different from any
other sort of fanaticism whether it's
political religious or you know people
that are just unhealthily you know
obsessed with anything that catches
their interest um i understand the
arguments for bitcoin and its uniqueness
as an asset and as a network um
but not
that it's the only interesting uh asset
and network that is leveraging
blockchains and uh some of the
cryptography that was first written
about in satoshi's white paper uh in in
2008 right so i think that's where you
can draw the distinction and i think you
know you're probably alluding to nick
carter and and the drama with uh with
nick i mean nick is
one of the smartest um longest-term
proponents for bitcoin and one of the
best evangelists for bitcoin and and
some of its technical underpinnings out
there um and his sin was uh being
open-minded enough to understand other
networks and other opportunities within
the crypto sphere so you know he was he
was routinely you know uh chastised and
and
just wrecked online for his uh you know
his supposed betrayal i guess i don't
know i don't know what purity test is
used i always use opportunities like
this little sound bites like you know
bitcoin maximalism as brain cancer um to
just like retweet and then block uh
every single person that you know is is
going to come out of the woodwork and
attack because of it
and it just creates a better experience
for me online so i i kind of routinely
put trump in the water
and
make sure that i don't have to hear from
those people because i just don't think
that you're you're gonna get anywhere if
um if that's your your narrow world view
um and uh and kind of the way that
you're gonna engage uh with that with
critics so is it fair to uh summarize
your thought process as like it is a
form of extremism and extremism whether
it's in politics or anywhere else is not
something that you think is healthy is
it like a fair character well it's not
only unhealthy i just think it's a sign
of
you know emotional and mental weakness
uh to not be able to entertain you know
multiple thoughts at the same time or
understand that you know any any kind of
nuanced views
towards um innovation and and tech right
i mean it's it's
it's literally i i mean it's it's it's
just it's crazy to me that um you have
some people that look at an invention
from 13 years ago and now it's a it's
like a sacred text
instead of a breakthrough innovation of
which we will have many others
deployed using this same kind of
underpinning technology um
so whether it's you know zk proofs and
all the innovations happening around
zcash i don't know if zcash is going to
win but zk proofs and zero knowledge
transactions and this privacy preserving
feature um that has been you know really
popularized because of the investment
around zk and crypto you know that's
going to be applied in many different
you know use cases outside of just money
um so
you know what does that say on other
blockchains is it another kind of
non-blockchain applications i think the
answer is yes for both but um bitcoin is
not necessarily going to be the network
that incorporates zero knowledge proofs
before any other so right off the bat
you're basically excluding one of the
most
interesting cutting edge areas of
cryptography out there
because you've got this you know
borderline religious know fanaticism
around
um the holy scripture of satoshi from 13
years ago just i mean
it's absurd on its face to basically
anybody
um that that really kind of
just looks at at the state of discourse
on crypto twitter but i think that's not
really an accurate indication of where
most people's heads are even um
crypto skeptics and bitcoin bulls right
most most people that fall into that
camper probably more similar to me and i
think you pomp where you're open-minded
everything you got pretty strong
conviction around one particular asset
and it's staying power and everything
else is a little bit more experimental
with lots of upside but a number of
unproven variables that that will be
de-risked over time
yeah i don't even have a huge problem
with people who uh generally believe
what they're saying and then their
actions like support it i think the part
that screams uh kind of um
i don't know unsustainable or just
comical is the hypocrisy like there's
certain people who uh will yell and
scream and kind of do the equivalent of
virtue signaling around a certain set of
ideals uh and then you look at whether
it's the things that they build or the
companies that they run or whatever and
you're like
you're literally doing the exact
opposite of what uh you're accusing
other people of doing or that you're
like projecting on other folks and so i
tend to agree with you that um just you
know look at politics as an example like
extreme left extreme right both is like
very unhealthy uh and so i tend to think
that um one of the most interesting data
points in all of the crypto industry
whether people like it or not
is that 87
of bitcoiners hold other assets there's
a bunch of folks who think that that
number will uh go down over time uh
there's a lot of folks who tend to think
that number is going to go up over time
but it used to be 100 of bitcoiners held
100
of bitcoin right like it was only
bitcoin um and that's changed and now
what we don't know in that data which i
think is a very fair critique of the
data is it like 87 of people have
bitcoin plus like some stable coins
and where do stable coins fall into the
whole thing right like are stable coins
considered
altcoins and therefore they're bad uh or
are they okay because they help people
get into bitcoin and i don't necessarily
have like a a strong opinion in either
way but like now you get into like the
nuance as you as you stated and i think
that the deeper you get into the
conversation the more obvious like a
black and white view of the world is
nearly impossible to overlay here right
well i mean the stable coin is one
example but the other thing is look at
d5 for instance um
if you are running a decentralized
exchange like uniswap and you know that
the market makers make fees and the
protocol could hypothetically make a
small
fee per transaction even if it's one
basis point for instance
then ultimately
there's ways to mutualize
[Music]
those revenues and those economics
across everyone that's participating you
know across the network um and that's
essentially what i think a lot of d5
protocols will be at scale there will be
user-owned networks um
where you know the traders are the same
as the you know quote-unquote equity
holders um
are the same as kind of the market
makers right so it's it's incentive
alignment and it's um ownership interest
uh on behalf of the market participants
themselves that's really interesting and
you can apply that to any of the other
uh kind of emerging application areas if
there is a fundamental use case that is
economically valuable and people are
willing to pay
for that on-chain
uh space those those ledger entries the
block space then ultimately anyone
that's involved with that network will
be able to um
you know take out some of the fees uh
that that are used to process those
transactions so it's it's no different
from you know how a number of uh
consortium work right now in traditional
finance um
it's just uh it's just new and and it
moves a hell of a lot faster because uh
you're talking about open source code
instead of you know six year old code
that was written uh in
you know ancient programming languages
that basically no longer exist uh on
behalf of the big banks and and you know
interchange uh operators so
um i think that's gonna be true for all
sorts of assets right i know you spoke
about nfts on on your podcast do i think
that you know uh digital art should be
worth you know ten dollars or a hundred
thousand well hey it depends on the
piece and b i don't know because that's
not really my jam but um i do know that
there's a market for art and digital art
so you know nfts could could be useful
in that context and then nfts as the
data wrapper could be useful far beyond
that but
again a lot of these things
um you know that they could be
interesting it's how do we get there
that is the the big open question for
the industry and we might go through
another period of consolidation where we
see
bitcoin dominance back above you know
eighty percent maybe even ninety percent
i doubt that happens but maybe we could
because that is the application as the
strongest product market fit right now
um but that's not to say that everything
will go to zero except for bitcoin
obviously that's false and we know it's
false because it's already been proven
false and there hasn't really been
strong evidence to support that that
everything else is going to zero much to
the chagrin and i think frustration of
the toxic uh bitcoin maximalist crowd
one of the uh themes that i think is
really interesting because you running
masari obviously are very aware of uh so
much of the non-bitcoin world what are
people building what's working what's
not working what do they hope is the the
kind of promise of it um and it seems
like now with the lightning network uh
and then their proposal for tarot on top
of lightning from lightning labs
uh that the same ideas feel to be in
both
kind of communities or ecosystems like
the bitcoin and non-bitcoin uh side of
the house how do you evaluate
lightning networks progress or the
tara proposal
in light of what you're seeing in the
rest of the market like are these things
just echo chambers for the bitcoin world
and they think that they're really um
kind of highly adopted and growing fast
but in your experience they aren't
compared to other things or is there a
strong argument there that those things
are actually becoming more popular
i think lightning is really interesting
um but it hasn't scaled
anywhere near as quickly uh as stable
coins on ethereum for instance that's
not an indictment of lightning in its
potential it's just a it's a factual
state of affairs and where the industry
is right now and where the tech is
it's also factual to just say that it is
orders of magnitude easier to build on
ethereum um and actually even on on new
emerging
stacks like solana than it is to build
on the bitcoin um stack for if you're a
developer thinking about a new
application
so um these are just raw numbers right
so
you can get people to debate about the
security model underpinning the the
blockchains themselves or about you know
what's coming next when it comes to
extensibility the bitcoin platform you
need to build on a really robust
foundation i think yeah those are
arguments to be had but in terms of
where we are today
in terms of capital in terms of human
capital and and brain power most of the
interest is still
on
emerging layer one protocols that are a
little bit more complete in terms of the
functionality and the application they
support like ethereum and uh and some of
the other so-called l1s um
it's just not happening at the same
speed or scale on bitcoin yeah um maybe
that maybe that changes um but i think
that uh the the sheer number
uh of people and kind of the caliber of
talent that are building outside of
lightning versus you know within the
bitcoin community it's it's pretty stark
and uh and it's it's not in favor of the
about bitcoins outlets right now if you
just look at the raw numbers
um i know that you recently heard uh the
all-in podcast uh i usually listen to it
but i have not seen uh the one from last
week uh i saw you tweeting saying that
uh you disagreed with their analysis of
crypto so maybe lay out what were their
arguments as you understood them and
then what do you agree or disagree with
uh from uh from that episode
well you know
you don't have anyone on that show
that's actually like
deep into crypto uh i think you you have
a few guys that are uh kind of aren't
chair quarterbacks they haven't really
done the work and kind of gotten deep
here um and that's fine right like and
first of all like i'm a huge fan i went
down to their summit and i think those
guys are super short because like an
entrepreneur and an investor like i've
gotten so much out of of uh listening to
a lot of their stuff just on macro and
and when you think about startup
investing um but they just they don't
really spend much time in cryptos that's
kind of understandable um and i was
giving them a little bit of a hard time
because um uh yeah chamath who i know
you've had on your shows in the past
he's brilliant and he did give a good
market structure breakdown of what
happened and how some of these lenders
went bust and all the shenanigans in
terms of you know the high interest rate
loans that people were speculating with
and defy and how some of these
insolvency issues came to the fore but i
think they conflated the centralized
with the decentralized number one they
don't really understand the policy
issues um and the fact that uh right now
we're operating in no man's land and no
one in the right line within crypto
is saying that we shouldn't be regulated
right it's that decentralized protocols
should not be regulated the same as
centralized institutions and why don't
you give us a little bit of clarity on
what the rules of engagement are so we
can safely integrate these centralized
financial um institutions and products
into the broader you know financial
ecosystem um and and and that is not a
like trivial mix-up or or uh or
distinction right you're on one hand
talking about an industry that has been
spending a lot of time collectively on
policy engagement and trying to make
sure that we have some good um we make
some good headway and we can solve some
of these structural issues
because we think it's in the long-term
best interest not only of the industry
but all the users and potential
beneficiaries of this tech um with just
some of the carp launch statements of
you know
everything's gripped and i haven't seen
any interesting use cases and you know
and so on and so forth when the other
reality is like i said a few minutes ago
all the on-chain protocols the
facilitate lending the facilitate
decentralized exchange uh and the like
they operated just fine it was all the
black box
quasi-centralized slash you know fully
centralized yeah black boxes that were
um operating in the gray area and
ultimately should be
um should be shut down they should fail
um and they should face you know
customer repercussions and lawsuits if
they're being responsible with customer
funds right that's
uh the i think what i took exception
with is no one in the industry that has
any credibility or seriousness
whatsoever disagrees that the last
couple of months were a huge black eye
and a bunch of people screwed up in some
cases should be going to jail for fraud
it looks like um but
this wouldn't necessarily happen if we
could get any momentum whatsoever on the
regulatory side uh so i i think painting
the entire industry and all of his
participants with that with a broad
brush
it's just you know it's it's a lack of
sophistication and generally that's to
be expected from people that don't spend
a lot of time here but um i was having
fun on twitter and and poking the
hornets nest as you know i do i know i'm
sure that they actually uh would agree
right i mean just given uh kind of who
they are and hearing uh them talk a lot
of stuff of like
they're just talking about it it's easy
to talk in generalities and then if you
really sat down and have a 30-minute
conversation with them there may be more
nuance to it uh so it's always hard
right but but i think to your point
about like the nuance is really
important uh is a is a fair one um do
you think that uh
the traditional venture capitalists not
necessarily those uh four individuals
but just in general
will we see them pull back from
investing in crypto now that asset
prices have come down and uh and they'll
kind of go away or do you anticipate
that you'll still have kind of the
crypto native uh investors plus you'll
have a lot of those uh non-crypto native
investors sticking around and continuing
to invest over the coming years
i think the variance is going to be huge
uh between firms so you're going to have
some firms that are run you know and and
the partnerships are
uh
full of a bunch of crypto skeptics that
are saying i told you so and and
basically just ceasing operations you'll
have uh others that are more open-minded
and thinking about this as an entry
point and saying hey how do we invest in
infrastructure companies we're in like
the next installation phase we're going
to be able to get get good entry prices
into good companies
and and businesses that are going to be
around for this next cycle when and
maybe solving problems that are
addressing the uh the the
institutional adoption and kind of
mainstream
adoption problems
and then you're going to have some
that are looking
at this on the token side and they're
saying
well we missed the last wave but now is
the opportunity now is the time for us
to go in and look at all these assets
that are now down 90
95 maybe even 99
which of these protocols actually have
value capture mechanisms and real
fundamentals behind them because there's
going to be so much mispricing in this
middle market of assets um it's insane
and it presents a ton of opportunities
so you think about assets number you
know like 25 through 300. forget about
the top 25 i don't necessarily think
this is true but let's assume the top 25
are super efficient and there's a lot of
information symmetry so people know what
they're doing and how to think about
these um as uh as relative allocations
once you go past that you know once you
drop down past a billion dollars of
market capitalization in in you know
research coverage drops um general you
know kind of awareness of these assets
and how they work in other communities
operate drops so you'll have um
investors that are willing to roll up
their sleeves get really really
interesting insights and kind of a
proprietary edge
making this middle market uh more
efficient
and um and actually you know one of our
star analysts uh ryan watkins just left
um a few months ago to start a company
called pangaea and their their focus is
to you know kind of take this approach
to the work and think about the the
middle market liquid stuff that's just
fundamentally mispriced if you look at
the underlying kind of you know value of
the protocols or what they anticipate
are going to be the value capture
mechanisms long term um
it's it's you know it couldn't be more
different and i think the um
the seed stage is going to continue to
hold up well because people think about
crypto is like one of the frontiers that
is going to be fundamentally interesting
like mobile was 10 years ago and like uh
like the internet was you know 10 years
before that so
um we got a lot of uh we had a lot of
room left to run and there's a lot of
dry powder that's sitting on the
sidelines ready to be deployed it's just
a matter of uh really when do people get
comfortable that the bottom's in and
when the macro situation settle down a
little bit and then when you start to
look at uh a lot of the fundraising that
occurred
up until i don't know 2017 maybe it was
either bitcoin related and equity um you
know kind of structured we then got the
boom of icos
and that kind of swept uh all of the
fundraising uh wind
now what are you seeing on the ground
how are people funding these efforts are
they funding them through you know some
variation of like ico slash like token
sale
uh are they just doing equity deals with
like token warrant like what what is
happening now
i think the good news is that a lot of
people already raised right so they're
they're they're ready to deploy um
and you know the companies that are are
having success raising right now
are either at the seed stage um and you
know just going from zero to one and you
have really high potential ideas that
and good teams that people are excited
about um
or uh they're they're somewhere on the
infrastructure side of things um so you
know what's going to be a good
directional bet on the industry um not
necessarily you know
taking massive you know uh at-risk bets
of 100 million dollar you know billion
dollar plus
um token networks when it's still
unclear how much
um those values gonna wane and how much
more bleeding there is um because
we just haven't seen a bottom
generally in in the macro backdrop and
in tech in general
so it's uh it's gonna be a lot easier to
just
uh price those private rounds uh maybe
with tier point like token warrants and
to the extent that there's a token
that's released by the team at some
point in the future
um but i'd say
um private placements or private kind of
token purchases from big venture firms i
would that's going to grind to a halt
for sure the last thing i want to talk
about is crypto and politics uh you have
uh i think at one point even said that
you might run for an office you have
been uh very quiet
no thoughts whatsoever when it comes to
politicians or regulators for that uh uh
um
on the internet
what's your thought right now in current
the current you know kind of position of
crypto when it comes to the political
landscape in america
i think
everything has been reset the last
quarter i have no idea um there's a few
things that happen in the in the last
quarter if you would ask me at the end
of march where are we i'd say
we're in a pretty good position because
it looks like republicans um are going
to retake congress and so you'll have
divided power which will kind of grind
the worst elements uh potentially of of
uh legislation down to a halt
um and then
you also have the dynamic war we are
studying getting starting to get more
informed um
uh champions on the left and that
progressive base that's going to be
really important so that this remains a
bipartisan effort when we do think about
more proactive legislation right so
first is
you know put sand in the gears to make
sure that the worst case scenario
doesn't play out and once there's a
balance of power now you have some
really smart champions on both sides hey
what can we hash out as an agreement
but there's a few things that happened
in the last quarter that i think throw
everything off
one is just um you know the three arrows
capital situation the luna situation
like all these cascading failures um and
and the black guy that that's given uh
the industry and the fact that a lot of
customers have lost funds and you start
you're going to start to hear more you
know uh like horror stories about people
losing their life savings and just like
terrible right um it's it's bad in
general but it's certainly bad also um
from a political optic standpoint um and
then you've got um everything that's
going on socially right so everything
out of the supreme court right now and
and just general impression that um
uh there there's going to be social
issues that start to drive the midterms
um if it was just about the economy
and you know kind of the the direction
that things are are heading um in the
macro uh backdrop with inflation and and
potential recessionary forces you know
you can think that we're gonna have
divided government in november now
that's not at all quite so obvious so um
we'll see i mean i'm
uh i'm net bullish still uh and i think
that the engagement efforts um from from
the big kind of crypto policy groups
have started to bear fruit and we're
going to have some really thoughtful
discussions uh with the new congress
realistically nothing's going to happen
from a legislative standpoint until
there's a new congress warning next
january the meantime is going to be
really about fighting some of these
regulatory battles that come from the
biden executive order
that was released a few months ago so
we'll see
um i think uh the battlegrounds are
going to be around the right to private
transactions the right to kind of
peer-to-peer commerce and a bunch of
those are going to go to the supreme
court which regardless of your opinion
on social issues is probably a net
positive for crypto as an industry
because um they're going to be uh i
think much more likely to look at some
of the fourth and first amendment issues
that are laid out in front of them when
it comes to crypto
when we think about massari the last
update i think i got was at the turn of
the year
what is the uh the mid-year update and
where can people go to uh to check out
some of that work
we've got a lot coming out uh throughout
the the third quarter the second half of
the year we've got our main net
conference where we'll have about 4 000
people in new york we're gonna have a
few big product releases and other kind
of major announcements there um if you
go to missouri.io we've got a full suite
of analytics tools research uh and and
asset diligence tools for uh for
individuals and enterprises alike most
of our
um business is you're really focused on
enterprise b2b but we offer a ton of you
know free resources as well as uh both
our top of the funnel and a you know
quasi public service so um happy to uh
have
people connect with me on twitter at two
bit idiots
and uh certainly happy to answer uh
other questions about some of the
opportunities to work with us as a
company and uh and hopefully you know
help some of these
new institutions that are entering the
fray uh get smarter on crypto
two-bit idiot still is one of the best
twitter handles on the entire website uh
i appreciate you coming on um
as someone said to me when i told them
that you were coming on they said oh he
has very uh
what did they say he has very mainstream
views and then they laughed and i was
like yes that's why i want to talk to
him is he he he continues to share uh
a thought process that i actually think
is uh is really important because what
if there's one thing that we've seen
over the last eight to 12 months is that
many of the widely held kind of
consensus views have been wrong that's
true in the macro environment that's
true in crypto and so having uh kind of
you constantly question why something
happening i think is uh incredibly
important
and
you know they may not like it but the
legacy system getting questioned uh by
you as well
here's the thing pomp and i think you
know this is true i know that was said
tongue-in-cheek but i actually think
that a lot of what i say is mainstream
people are just too afraid to pipe up so
i i think that that is actually more
true than people will admit
is that uh i've i've seen it like you've
tweeted some things and somebody sent me
a tweet or something and they're like he
nailed it and i'm always like why don't
you just respond with you nailed it and
like no no no no
the internet it doesn't forget it
doesn't forget um awesome man well
listen thank you so much for taking the
time to uh to come on here we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thanks bob all right see you later
i really enjoy that conversation with
ryan and i hope that you guys enjoy it
as well don't forget that these episodes
are brought to you by ftx us you can go
click on the link in the description ftx
has super cheap trading fees sometimes
as much as 85 cheaper than their
competitors they also now offering
digital stocks which allow you to go buy
stocks in their beta testing and it will
give you no transaction fees and also no
payment for order flow that is some
great pricing go check out ftx us today
click on the link in the description to
get started hope you enjoy this episode
and i'll see you at the next one